good afternoon and welcome back to the
Hillsdale College Constitution Town Hall
we're pleased that you can join us today
as we continue through our trek
exploring the Constitution with the
ultimate objective of in fact reviving
the Constitution this afternoon we're
going to turn now from America's
Founding and the Civil War period to the
progressive eras it's sometimes called
if you're interested in finding more
about the progressive movement there are
many books about them but none better
than a collection of readings that was
assembled by our next speaker American
progressivism is edited by Ronald J post
read oh we're pleased that he's joined
us today at Hillsdale College professor
he has written a lot on Woodrow Wilson I
should ask of all of you that as you
consider and listen to the the talks the
remaining two presentations today if you
have a question that pops into your mind
or if you have a question about any of
the mornings about proceedings or
anything that might pertain to Hillsdale
College what we're doing in Washington
or any of the other programs if you're
interested in admissions information
please email us the easiest email to use
is Kirby Center at Hillsdale dot edu
Kirby Center at Hillsdale edu we're
going to now turn to our program on
American progressivism and I'm going to
ask Hillsdale College student Andrew
O'Dell
to come forward and introduce our
speaker Andrew is a junior he's
interning at the Heritage Foundation
this semester he's studying interning
there at the Center for legal and
judicial studies Andrew
Rjay post Reno is Charles and Lucia
Shipley chair in the American
Constitution an associate professor of
political science at Hillsdale College
he is a senior fellow at the Kirby
Center dr. post Rita earned his Bachelor
of Arts magna [ __ ] laude at Claremont
McKenna College and his master's and
doctorate in government at the Claremont
Graduate University he is the author of
Woodrow Wilson and the roots of modern
liberalism the editor of Woodrow Wilson
the essential political writings and the
co-editor of American progressivism a
reader challenges to the American
Founding slavery historicism and
progressivism in the nineteenth century
and the American Founding in the social
compact
he is also written for the Claremont
Review of Books and The Wall Street
Journal
he is a frequent guest on the Fox News
Channel as recently as last night please
join me in welcoming dr. post rito as he
speaks on the topic the progressives
Constitution thank you Andrew thanks to
the Kirby Center for inviting me to
participate get the chance to to speak
to you this afternoon and thanks for for
coming out and braving the the weather
we're having here in the greater DC area
the the program this morning the
previous sessions sort of concentrated
on America's first principles and the
reason therefore for for America's
greatness and as is usually the case
I've been given the role of throwing
some cold water on the festivities it's
my duty to talk about where things went
off the rails in America's political
tradition and that's that's usually my
job and it I think is an important one
because if work we aim to go about
restoring what is good about our country
we certainly first have to understand
where it is that we we lost our way my
own scholarly work over the last several
years as Andrew mentioned in his
introduction has focused on the
Progressive Era
my earlier work was on the founding
period but the more I studied the
founding the more it was fairly clear
that there was a very wide gulf between
the principles of the founding and the
way in which we govern ourselves today
the principles of our current political
culture so this led me on a sort of a
journey in search of the reason for this
gulf and that led me to the progressives
so today I want to say something about
the progressive movement which I hope
will prepare us for the day's concluding
discussion of the problem of our current
administrative state and some possible
ways forward thought I talk first about
liberalism today or today's liberals and
to observe the fact that today's
liberals for the most part seem to think
that it's too dangerous for them to be
known as liberals instead as you've
probably noticed the the popular term
that they used to refer to themselves is
now progressives and if you think back
to the presidential campaign of 2008
there was a particularly memorable
debate on the Democratic side where mrs.
Clinton was asked directly if she
considered herself to be a liberal and
she made it very clear that she wanted
nothing to do with that label but said
instead that she considered herself to
be a proud modern American progressive
and indeed she may recall she often
referred to her agenda as a progressive
vision for America now in one sense it's
certainly the case that that the
aversion to the word liberal today is a
legacy of the national political debate
of the 1980s this is where a liberal
became a dirty word and it still it
still is to a certain degree in American
politics but I think more importantly
liberals today identified themselves as
progressives because modern liberalism
really has come home to its progressive
roots modern big government liberalism
as opposed to classical or founding era
liberalism my modern big government
liberalism was born in America's
progressive era for mrs. Clinton at
least the term progressive I think was
not simply some kind of vague platitude
not simply a nicer way of saying liberal
she made clear she had the Progressive
Era in mind explained in response to
that question in the presidential debate
no go back to the turn of the twentieth
century that's where I'm placing myself
so what was this progressive era what is
the connection between it and modern
liberalism well the progressive era was
the first major period in American
political development to feature as a as
a primary characteristic the open and
direct criticism of the US Constitution
now of course while criticism of the
Constitution can be found during any
period of American history the
progressive era was really the first
time where that kind of criticism formed
the backbone of a movement all right the
the Progressive Era criticism of the
Constitution did not come simply from a
few you know fringe characters all right
rather the most prominent thinkers the
most prominent politicians of that era
made those criticisms of the
Constitution readers are reminded in any
almost any progressive text that they
pick up that the Constitution is old
that it was written to deal with
circumstances that had long ago been
replaced by a whole new set of pressing
social and economic ills crying out for
a new kind and expansive kind of
government problem-solving
now our progressives understood the
intention and the structure of the
Constitution very well they knew that
the Constitution established the
framework for limited government they
knew that these limits were to be upheld
by a variety of institutional mechanics
for lack of a better term a variety of
institutional restraints and checks they
also knew that the limits placed on the
national government by the Constitution
represented major obstacles to
implementing the progressive agenda of
public policy what did they have in mind
they had in mind a variety of proposals
a variety of legislative programs aimed
at regulating significant portions of
the American economy and and society
they were aimed at redistributing
private property in the name of social
justice the Constitution if interpreted
faithfully and accurately stood in the
way of this progressive legislative
agenda now the Constitution of course
was only a means to an end and and
that's something that was that was
talked about at some length in this
morning sessions the Constitution was
crafted and adopted for the sake of
achieving the natural rights principles
of the American Declaration of
Independence the progressives also
understood this fact very clearly and
it's why that so many of the more
theoretical works that progressives
wrote feature very sharp attacks on what
we call social compact theory basically
on the principles of the Declaration and
the notion that the fundamental purpose
of government is to secure the
individual natural rights of citizens
and this is why in the in the reader
that our studio audience has here before
them one of the things that I included
the first selection is a lecture by a
fellow by the name of Frank
who is a very important progressive
intellectual and if you want an example
of a Progressive Era piece that really
has to go after the theory of the
Declaration the theory of social compact
the idea that natural rights are the end
of government that good no pieces is a
very nice encapsulation of this kind of
progressive argument it begins on page
101 of your of your reader if you have
it now while most of the founders and
while nearly nearly all ordinary
Americans did not subscribe to some of
the more radical implications of some of
the social compact philosophers in the
Western political tradition they did
they did believe in inline with the the
English political thinker John Locke
that men as individuals possessed rights
by nature rights that any just
government was bound to uphold and
rights which stood as inherent limits to
the authority of government over
individual liberty and property so the
regulatory aims and the redistributed
aims of progressivism were therefore on
a collision course with the political
theory of the founding in this this
basic fact of which again progressives
were very well aware
it makes understandable Woodrow Wilson's
admonition and this was in an address
ostensibly honoring Thomas Jefferson
Wilson admonished quote if you want to
understand the real Declaration of
Independence do not repeat the preface
the preface would be that part of the
Declaration you know with those small
items like natural equality god-given
rights and all of all of that
unimportant stuff right
don't don't repeat that what are you
left with you're you're left with the
litany of grievances against George the
third that is to say you're left with
the Declaration which is applicable only
to that period of time and doesn't have
any relevance going forward
now to make what can be a very long
story reasonably short and and some
students in the room who've had me in
class know that this can be a long story
they've had the longer version of it but
to make it reasonably short out of out
of Mercy for you to say something about
the administrative state today and it's
and its origins and and I define the
administrative state as one where the
extent of governmental power is defined
not by the enumerations of it that are
in the Constitution but instead by
whatever perceived social ill happens to
catch our attention at a given moment
and we're a large unelected bureaucratic
apparatus that has been set up to
regulate virtually every aspect of our
economy and society on the basis of
expertise as opposed to consent this is
the administrative state than it is the
fulfillment of the progressives dream
for transforming American government or
at least it goes a long way toward
fulfilling it progressives imported the
philosophy of the all-powerful state
into America from Europe and this
philosophy of the all-powerful state was
the driving force behind the
programmatic liberalism of the 20th
century and beginning in the Progressive
Era
from the progressives to the New Deal
New Deal to the Great Society and really
maintained by the by the presidential
administrations of both major political
parties from from the 1880s into the
1920s and even beyond the likes of
Theodore Roosevelt Woodrow Wilson John
Dewey Herbert Crowley and a host of
others contended that the American
Constitution was outdated it was no
longer appropriate for the economic and
social ills of contemporary times that
if applied at all this is a phrase
you've probably heard before that the
Constitution ought to be applied
as a so-called living document right
that notion of a living Constitution
that language of a living Constitution
which of course now is up as a pillar of
modern liberalism and one hears it then
in debates about Supreme Court
nominations and and and big Supreme
Court cases that language comes from the
Progressive Era and before that it came
from the the historicism of German
political philosophy which is where the
progressives learned it the progressives
I should add had a robust German
pedigree almost all of them were
educated in Germany or had as teachers
those who had been educated in Germany
now what did the progressives get from
the Germans well among other things they
took from the Germans their championing
of the state over the individual a
notion which drove their policy agenda
as they looked to redistribute wealth as
they look to use the national government
to superintend private business and
other aspects of the economy and our
society as I've said this agenda ran
squarely up against the natural rights
principles of the founding the limited
scope of of our national government
under the Constitution but as Theodore
Roosevelt is reported to have quipped
when he was challenged about his
intrusion on property rights during a
coal strike in 1902 to hell with the
Constitution when people want coal now
some contend perhaps perhaps correctly
that that remark is apocryphal but
nonetheless they ought to consider that
the remark simply encapsulates the
progressive philosophy of government
that Theodore Roosevelt very clearly and
very deliberately endorsed on numerous
occasions there may be no better example
of this than Roosevelt's speech that he
called the new nationalism which he gave
in 1910 this is after he'd returned
from Africa was becoming dissatisfied
with the Taft administration and was was
set soon thereafter to launch his bid to
recapture the presidency and this is
speech I've included in in your in your
reader as well it it for those of you in
the studio audience who have it it
begins on page 107 in that speech
Roosevelt called for the states to take
an active role in effecting economic
equality both equality of opportunity as
he called it and equality of reward how
by having the government superintend the
use of private property private property
rights which had been serving as a brake
on some of the more aggressive
progressive policy proposals were to be
respected Roosevelt argued only insofar
as the government approved of the
property's utility okay and if we take a
look at that new nationalism speech if
you have it in front of you on page 110
of your reader here's a passage from
Roosevelt's new nationalism speech on
this very point Roosevelt said the
following
we grudge no man a fortune in civil life
if it is honorably obtained and well
used it is not even enough that it
should have been gained without doing
damage to the community we should permit
it to be gained only so long as the
gaining represents benefit to the
community this I know
implies a policy of a far more active
governmental interference in within
social and economic conditions in this
country than we have yet had but I think
we have got to face the fact that such
an increase in governmental control is
now necessary so new circumstances
according to Roosevelt necessitated a
new conception of government natural
rights were no longer to serve as a
principled boundary that the state was
forbidden from crossing Woodrow Wilson
had outlined
a similar view of the extent of state
power and a concise but very revealing
essay called socialism and democracy
this I've also included in your reader
beginning on page 119 it's an essay that
Wilson wrote in I believe 1887 the essay
starts out by defining socialism and
suggest that what socialism stands for
is unfettered state power which Trump's
or overcomes any notion of individual
rights again for those of you in the
audience on page 120 of your of your
reader Wilson says the following in this
essay here he's defining socialism state
socialism is willing to act through
state authority as it as at present
organized it proposes that all idea of a
limitation of public authority by
individual rights be put out of view and
that the state consider itself bound to
stop only at what is unwise or futile in
its universal superintendence alike of
individual and of public interests the
thesis of the state socialists is that
no line can be drawn between private and
public affairs which the state may not
cross at will right so that's that's
socialism according to Wilson and after
he lays out this definition of socialism
in the essay he explains he finds
nothing wrong with it in principle since
it is merely the logical extension of
how he understood genuine democracy says
it gives all power to the people in
their collective capacity to carry out
their will through the exercise of
governmental power unlimited by any
undemocratic idea like individual rights
as he goes on to explain in fundamental
theory he says in this essay on the same
page in fundamental theory socialism and
democracy are all most if not quite one
end the same they both rest at bottom
upon the absolute right of the community
to determine its own destiny and that of
its members right not just socialism but
the mocker
see men as communities are supreme as
men over individuals limits of wisdom
and convenience to the public control
there may be limits of principle there
are upon strict analysis none so in this
view rights based theories of government
like the republicanism to which the
American founders subscribed and of
which Wilson of course was sharply
critical they're far less democratic
than socialism and as Wilson and his
fellow progressives believed
rights-based theories of government
limit the state's sphere of action and
thus they limit the ability of people to
implement their collective will and thus
represent something less than real
democracy so these these general
principles led to action on a wide
variety of fronts many of which dealt
with the social reform educational
reform some of which even led to
religious movements like social gospel
which was bound up with progressivism in
some interesting ways these are all very
important of course but but too numerous
to to get into in any detail here
instead let me mention more concretely
in the time that I have laughed the
progressive policy agenda which included
an array of proposals to regulate
private business and property in many
states progressives had met with
considerable success in winning
enactment of these policies yet the
Federal Constitution undergirded at it
as it is by the idea of property rights
continued to provide a formal formidable
obstacle to these progressive policy
successes as did many of the state
constitutions and so state state courts
had in many cases overturned progressive
legislative achievements ruling that the
new programs extended the power of
government into the private sphere
unconstitutionally the most famous
example of course probably the case of
Lochner V New York from 1905 it was a
case overturning state regulation of
Baker's hours
this this phenomenon of states state
courts stepping in and and a stopping
legislation that was deemed to violate
constitutional rights
this was the phenomenon that Roosevelt
had in mind Theodore Roosevelt when he
frequently railed against the judiciary
and he called he even called for a
people to be given the power through
popular referenda to overturn state
judicial decisions he said that the
courts were construing the due process
clause quote as if property rights to
the exclusion of human rights had a
first mortgage on the Constitution now
at a more general level the real problem
as progressives saw it was a failure of
the courts to see the Constitution as a
living organism one whose limitations on
government ought not be read strictly or
literally but instead interpreted to fit
the new demands of a new age for Woodrow
Wilson the structure of the Constitution
itself made it nearly impossible for
progressively inclined interpreters to
adapt it to their agenda the
Constitution rested at bottom of course
on a system of divided powers both
between the federal and state levels and
then within the federal government
itself between the different branches of
government and so you had in Wilson's
view this idea that the progressive
force of history had brought about this
great unity in the public mind but the
problem was the Constitution divided
power in such a way so as to make
expression of that unified will a near
impossibility it was for this reason
that Woodrow Wilson detested the
separation of powers and that almost
everything he wrote on the American
system of government contained a sharp
critique of separation of powers the
ideal model for Wilson was a
parliamentary model he was an Anglophile
where the legislature and the executive
are essentially unified both rising or
falling on the evolving public opinion
indeed many of Wilson's early writings
by the way advocated
actual changes to the Constitution to
make it more amenable to a parliamentary
style the separation of powers as Wilson
explained had come out of the founders
obsessive fear of majority tyranny and
their obsession
especially with property rights and the
problem was outlined by Wilson on the
campaign trail in 1912 giving you a
speech from his 1912 presidential
campaign it's it's called what is
progress for those of you in the studio
audience and I'd like to read you a
passage from that speech on page 117
this thumbs up Wilson's critique of the
Constitution Wilson wrote or he actually
sat on the campaign trail the makers of
our Federal Constitution read
Montesquieu with true scientific
enthusiasm they were scientists in their
way the best way of their age those
fathers of the nation Jefferson wrote of
the laws of nature and then by way of
afterthought and of nature's God and
they constructed a government as they
would have constructed an orrery to
display the laws of nature politics and
their thought was a variety of mechanics
the Constitution was founded upon the
law of gravitation the government was to
exist and move by virtue of the efficacy
of checks and balances the trouble with
this theory is that government is not a
machine but a living thing and there's
that language of the living Constitution
right it falls not under the theory of
the universe but under the theory of
organic life it is accountable to Darwin
not to Newton it is modified by its
environment necessitated by its tasks
shaped to its functions by the sheer
pressure of life no living thing can
have its organs offset against each
other ass checks and live surfaces great
wilsonian phrase so what had to happen
here in Wilson's view American
government needed to be reformed needed
to reflect the essential unity of the
public mind that progressives believed
had been brought about by history
so separation of powers had to be
discarded
it had to be replaced instead by a
system which separated politics and
administration and by this formulation
what they meant was that the national
political institutions Congress the
presidency and so on they ought to be
democratized they ought to be unified
and we're familiar with a lot of the
progressive proposals that that aim
aimed to bring that about they ought to
be brought it to much closer connection
with public opinion at the same time
since progressives believed that the
most contentious political questions had
already been settled by historical
development the Civil War was really
decisive in this regard then the real
work of government they believed was not
in politics but in administration in
these expert agencies and figuring out
what the experts and the agencies would
do is they would figure out the specific
means required to achieve what the
people generally agreed they all wanted
or at least what the progressives said
they all wanted and it's in this way of
course that the progressives became
influential not only upon the
development of our traditional political
institutions but also on the rise of the
federal bureaucracy and of course the
very significant role played by federal
agencies in setting and enforcing
national policy today most policy in
this country is made by federal agencies
who have that power delegated to them
with very broad or vaguely worded laws
that come from Congress so I'm going to
stop there I think because I believe
that dr. Arnn will be taking up the
topic of the administrative State among
other things I suspect in his remarks
later so we'll we'll stop and I look
forward to taking your questions and
again thank thanks for attending today
we do have time for questions I'd invite
our studio audience members to go to one
of the two microphones again if you're
at home watching Kirby Center at
Hillsdale edu we'll begin with the
question and before I jump into that I
wanted to mention that the Hillsdale
town hall reader is online it's at the
Kirby Center website so anybody can
download that reader and there's also a
different version a slightly larger
version and infecting contains 100
documents essential to understanding the
American Constitution that's also
located at the Kirby Center website this
question comes from Joe in Sherwood
Michigan yesterday at the House
Republican retreat in Baltimore
President Obama declared I am NOT an
ideologue yet throughout the campaign
and since his inauguration the president
has declared that he is a progressive
using the president's own words then can
a progressive not be an ideologue yeah
that's actually very a very good
question and in one sense you have to
remember that a movement that sort of
bound up with progressivism and in some
fairly complicated ways is its
pragmatism and and in a way the the idea
of pragmatism or somebody who's
pragmatic is of course exactly
antithetical to someone who is an
ideologue what what what the pragmatist
thought and and this of course was was
very congenial by and large to the
progressive idea of a living
Constitution was that you needed to have
a kind of functional understanding of
the Constitution right you needed you
needed to see the Constitution in light
of the particular thing you wanted to
bring about the particular task that you
needed the government to accomplish and
so the in legal circles we call this
today funk functionalism so in that
sense I think Barack Obama is very much
a someone who's pragmatic
that that is to say he is not willing to
have principles of the Constitution be
an impediment to an agenda that he
believes the government needs to needs
to follow now the justification for this
pragmatism or this progressivism is of
course very ideological there's a whole
understanding of of the role of the
state that that comes from certain
principles that the progressives learned
I won't bore you to death by by going
into the origin of these principles and
political philosophy so I guess the
answer to my to my question is yes you
can be both an ideologue and and also a
pragmatic our second question comes live
from the studio sir good afternoon thank
you doctor I'm David Hamilton from
Hillsdale Michigan by way of Woodbridge
Virginia welcome and I'm curious if you
would please jonah goldberg in liberal
fascism described how the education
system as we know it today was built in
part to remove God from from the supreme
being ship in the United States and
replaced that with the state could you
discuss that function and how it's
affected our ability to have a
constitutional government sure we have
to keep in mind that that the
relationship of progressivism
and and faith is is complicated because
many progresses although certainly not
all progressives but many progressives
were men and women of profound faith you
know Wilson himself among them Theodore
Roosevelt certainly there was a close
relationship between the progressive
movement and the social gospel movement
at the Progressive Party convention in
1919 12 the you know the party stalwarts
were waving Bibles
at the end and singing onward Christian
soldiers so it's it's on the one end
it's not the case then that that
progressivism is severed from some sort
of faith but I think the way your
question put it goes in the right
direction that that the faith was
altered in such a way to see to see
God's presence in the state that God and
the state or God and the public
Enterprise became became one in the same
and so that the way that one expressed
one's faith the way one lived one's life
and again in in in view most of these
folks as a Christian was to give of
oneself to the enterprise of the state
and that and that too is very much a
product of of 19th century philosophy
it's what's going on in that in in the
Darwinian revolution the idea that
somehow and we I guess we could say you
can see the way some progressives talk
certainly the way Wilson talked he
talked as if his public enterprise his
public policies were a manifestation of
God's very well and thus became you know
almost incredulous when people would
resist because it was essentially you
know like resisting the will of God
itself as Wilson understood that I
believe that was a very sincere of you
and in his mind
this is from Laura in Denton Texas so if
the progressive ideology and an agenda
have been steadily advancing now for a
hundred years then why don't you see a
similar progression of thought and
conservatism is it possible to have
progress as a conservative it feels as
if sometimes all I have to say about
politics is no stop or too much how
would a citizen like me convey us a
conservative message that is full of
ideas and hope and real progress for
America yeah that's an excellent
question and it's why I think we have to
realize that conservatism has to be
something more than a mere disposition
it has to be more than a kind of set of
cautions or a kind of a tendency to to
uphold the status quo if conservatives
and and you know that's that's a very
broad term but let's say if if those of
us who value the Constitution and want
to see it restored if we're to make any
any headway it seems to me that the
questioner is exactly right we have to
be able to articulate what it is about
the Constitution that's worthwhile why
why is it that government ought to be
limited what are these rights what are
they what are the foundation of these
rights why ought they to be aimed at why
ought they to be pursued and secured
that's that's the sort of positive brand
of conservatism that it seems to me it
has to be understood and embraced and
and the problem I think with with a lot
of elements of conservatism is right now
it's just a kind of disposition it's a
kind of caution if you think about it by
the way who the people who really behave
like conservatives today well they're
the people we would call liberals again
I'm thinking of the the Supreme Court
confirmation hearings spectacle that we
often see who is it who is up there and
in those in those hearings on those
committees calling for an adherence to
precedent cautioning against judicial
activism it's not the you know that the
so-called conservatives that's so-called
right-wingers it's the left
well why is that it's because the
present order is an order it's a it's a
progressive liberal order it's one
that's been established both through
judicial action and legislative action
over the course of the last 80 80 to 100
years that's that's the current American
paradigm that's where we are as a
country and have been for a long time
thanks again really to both both
political parties and so to simply have
a disposition for caution or a
disposition to for the status quo well
the status quo from the point of view of
someone who's who's a constitutionalist
really isn't satisfactory and the status
quo is the problem
so we need to be able to articulate you
know what is it about the Constitution
that makes it worthy as an object of of
our devotion Melissa from Plymouth
Minnesota how is the modern presidency
been shaped by the progressives what
should the executives role be comparing
the founders to that of progressivism
well I teach two courses on that at
Hills at Hillsdale of course on the
presidency and of course on the
progressives and I treat this question
in both of them at great length so I
suppose we can we can extend this for
another hour or so right the session I'm
sure dr. Arnn won't object to that no
quite very briefly you know I have to
say I think it's the case this is a you
know slight generalization but not the
modern presidency is the progressive
presidency
we look to the president today not
simply as the leader of a single branch
of government and don't get me wrong
it's not like the Federalists didn't
want an energetic executive they did
that that was a defect of the Articles
right but they also believe very
strongly in a separation of powers
Woodrow Wilson wrote famously now
eloquently about this in his book
constitutional government which
published in 1908 and he said you know
the problem with this separation of
powers arrangement is
we don't have any leadership in this
country leadership has to be lodged
somewhere and in our current system it's
sort of a three-headed monster and so
Wilson looked for somewhere some entity
out there in our system of government to
kind of rise above the separation of
powers and be able to bring all of the
branches together and move them in the
direction that he believed history was
traveling and initially Wilson thought
this might be Congress as a young man
he'd figured out that was a mistake
quite pretty quickly and looked and
looked to the presidency right so the
presidency for Wilson was something that
wasn't simply about being an executive
it was about really being a leader and
Wilson distinguished between the
constitutional aspects of the presidency
and the political aspects of the
presidency and the constitutional
aspects you got stuff an article to the
actual powers of the presidency that's
not really very important what really
matters is the president's connection to
public opinion his ability to be able to
draw upon his popular mandate he's the
only officer who gets a national vote
other than the vice-president who runs
runs with him on the same ticket and he
needs to translate that mandate that
popular vote into a direction for the
country as a whole and so the presidency
is the way we're going to rise above the
separation of powers well of course
that's exactly how we look at the
president today we look at elections as
mandates we look to our presidents and
again this is something that that has
been forwarded by presidents of both
parties of course we look to our
presidents as popular leaders as
legislative leaders almost as prime
ministers who are going to we want to
know on the campaign trail you know what
what legislation are you going to pass
when you become president this is you
hopefully know by now is not really the
constitutional role the president
although he's given a given a role in
legislation through the veto so it's
it's a question that requires a much a
much longer answer but there is much
about today's presidency that is the
product of of progressivism I talked
about Wilson but
you could say the same about Roosevelt
as well this comes from Doug from Tucson
Arizona and this will be our final
question for this session what did the
progressives think of political parties
again great great question I tried to
point out here that the progressive
movement was not strictly speaking a
partisan movement or the property of any
one political party of course you had
you know TR and the Republicans and
Wilson and the Democrats and you had
strong progressive elements of both
parties and so as progressive ideology
has has moved forward over the course of
the 20th and now 21st century it's it's
a bipartisan thing in terms of what they
thought about political parties there
was a bit of a dispute about that
between the wing of the movement that
was sort of headed by Theodore Roosevelt
on the wing that was headed by Woodrow
Wilson they both had the same objective
however they both thought that parties
as they existed in the 19th century were
an obstacle to progressive aims
they were undemocratic they got in the
way of the people being able to have
their will expressed in governmental
action they were this unnecessary middle
step party bosses were unaccountable the
party system was corrupt right where
they differed was over what the remedy
was Wilson thought that parties could be
reformed and be made the instruments or
tools of progressive leadership so
Wilson said look we have this separation
of power system we got federalism we got
this fragmentation of power all over the
place if we could just make the parties
accountable to the people that's why I
advocated primaries right if we can make
the parties accountable to the people
put the amateurs in charge not the
professional party leaders then they
could be the tools of leadership right a
strong president of a particular party
could use his party ties to move all of
the officials in the different branches
of government in a single direction it's
a way of coordinating sway of overcoming
separation of powers a way of overcoming
federalism so let's reform parties but
let's make them
progressive tools TR Herbert Crowley as
well as progressive intellectual I was
influential on TR thought parties were
incorrigible they the way they were they
could not be reformed they would always
remain obstacles to to progressive aims
and so therefore they had to be done
away with altogether and so the
Progressive Party the the rubric under
which Roosevelt ran in 1912 was a party
to end parties thank you very much